hello everyone and welcome to a really
nice game that just ended from the super
bets chess classic uh it's a game uh
between two former 2800s chocolate
mamidarov and levon arunyan
and it's uh well it features a move that
uh it's
it's not it isn't easily explained and
uh especially since this is a classical
game if i didn't tell you this was a
classical game you you would not believe
me it's a classical game you'd probably
think
uh okay it's a rapid or maybe blitz but
definitely not classical and
the move in question uh was made with
over one hour on the clock so that's
really
uh insane but uh to you know uh bring it
a bit closer to you let's uh dive
straight into it
so mommy with the white pieces opens
with d4
uh that's not a d4 we have knight to f6
c4
uh and now e6 uh we have knight two f3
and d5 so just a normal queen's gambit
declined not the god of the ordinary
happening
uh we have knight to c3 and the bishop
to b4 going for the ira goes in defense
uh we have queen to a4 check now you
have to block with the knight
because the bishop would hang so knight
to c6
and e3 now now with castles and now
bishop to d2 so
this has all been played before many
many times d
captures on c for bishop captures and
now the bishop goes back bishop to d6
uh the bishop will be much more useful
on this diagonal uh in the future you
will have support if you want to play e5
and it's just a well a very nice piece
there
and here the the most common replies
from white are
just castles and knights to b5 just
going after that bishop that already
weighs the two tempi getting there
uh but here we have just queen back to
c2 by mommy jarv and
now comes e5 the white king is still in
the center of the board so it makes
sense to
maybe open up the position and get the
rook into the game
uh here we have d captures on e5 knight
captures on e5
uh knight captures on e5 we have knight
captures on e5
and bishop captures on e5 and now f4
uh pushing this bishop back and now this
leaves white with a
for the moment a bit weak uh e3 pawn
but uh it shouldn't be a problem bishop
captures on c3 was played
we have bishop captures and not knight
to g4 so still
the white king in the center of the
board and still the king remains there
now
uh there's the danger of course of just
knight captures on e3 so bishop to d4
defends this
and now comes c5 and this is all been
played before
uh many times now the point behind this
point pawn sacrifices
uh that white has to capture it uh
there's really not
or anything there's really nothing else
you can do if you move the bishop then
you will lose this pawn
so here bishop captures and now the
queen covers the d1 square so you are
preventing the king from castling queen
side
that's uh the the important part here if
you just played
something else for example if you just
want to play rook to e8 put more
pressure
on this pawn then you can even play
queen side castles and you don't care
about this because well now the rook is
aligned with the queen
so uh like i said after bishop to b4 we
have c5
bishop captures on c5 and now rook the
e8 now
there is the uh threat of just knight
captures on e3
uh but also the white king cannot castle
queen side so here we have castle's
king's side
uh and now comes knight captures on e3
uh the position again has been reached
before uh it has been reached by wesley
so and the niche gear and nichiri had
the white pieces here in the grand
chester in paris
uh in 2016 the game ended in a draw but
in that game b6 was played preparing
bishop to b7
but here we have bishop captures um
other knight captures on e3 right away
bishop captures an e3 and rook captures
an e3
so what do you play here it's uh well
it's a fine position for both white and
black
uh here white plays rook f2 e1 and this
is where our game takes a new turn there
is a
a pretty famous game uh between uh
andreikin and
carlson from the world blitz
championship in 2019 in moscow
uh that andreikin won he defeated
carlson in this line where queen to f2
was
played and also there's a game between
ambassador and anna from defeated grand
swiss
in 2019 where also queen to f2 was
played so queen to f2 is a normal
rook after e1 on the other hand is a new
move so now already as of move 18 we
have a completely new game
uh so let's see how levon deals with
this uh he
accepts the rook we have rook capture
sunny one with check rook capture sunny
one
and now comes bishop to d7 so
that doesn't seem like much just uh
trading rooks and not playing bishop to
d7 seems
like a very passive move uh but there
there is
nothing better uh you you don't really
have the option of developing here it's
defended twice the queen covers the f5
square
and while you could play bishop to g4
it's again
uh not maybe at the most uh the
the safest of most just queen b3 now we
have a double attack on f7 also an
attack on b7
and it's very easy for black to go wrong
here let's say queen c7 you defend
against
both threats but now comes h3 and now
what do you do with the bishop if bishop
f5
we can just play g4 and now again where
is this bishop going you can't go
here because then we can just trap the
bishop the queen covers g3 so there
aren't any tricks here
and uh well if you go you can't go here
this is attack three times you can't go
here because the queen then doesn't
cover the f7 square
and of course if you go here you just
get checkmated there's also that
so instead after rook capture 71 we have
bishop to d7 uh it's a little bit of a
passive move but you have to
uh make certain concessions in order not
to blunder the game
right away so queen to b3 again with a
double attack here
and now comes queen to f6 offering the
b7 pawn
it's hard not to give away the spawn uh
because if you try something like bishop
to c6 to guard
this one and allow bishop captures on f7
uh well this is playable you are now
down upon and um levon prefers not to be
down this pawn he prefers to be
down this pawn so here we have queen to
b3
queen to f6 like we said and now queen
captures on b7
and now the rook is under attack so what
do you do here this is what levon had in
mind he plays queen to d4 with
check king to h1 and now yes the bishop
is under attack but so is the rook here
on a8 so you have to defend
the rook and you have to play uh rook to
f8 rook to d8 also playable rook to f8
is better
however in the game levon played rook
the e8 and this allows mamidarov to
well just to gain a winning advantage
because he's already up a pawn
and if he can grab a little bit more
material he will be
winning so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the move mamijaro
played while i give you a couple of
seconds
so a photo who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that it's
either the f-pawn or
it's checkmate uh and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook capture 78 with check bishop
captures and now
bishop captures an f7 with check and
the problem is there's no no good reply
to this because of course the king
cannot capture the queen is guarding the
bishop
uh if the bishop captures then you can
choose queen eight queen b8 queen to ca
to check all of them lead to checkmate
there's only one move okay you could
give up the queen first but it basically
ends with bishop to e8 and queen capture
78 with checkmate
so here after bishop captures an f7 it's
uh well it's
uh basically uh a resigned position but
not quite
uh as white still has some back rank uh
weaknesses so if
if you're not careful you might get
checkmated yourself
so here we have king to f8 you have to
play like this he's still hoping for
some back rank ideas
uh but now just bishop back to b3 so
snatching upon and now guarding that
d1 square and now while you could play
something like queen captures on b2
then you get the incredible queen to be
for checkmate
it's uh easy to fall for such such
things but of course this is what he had
in mind when he
plays the bishop back to b3 defend and
attack
so here we have queen to c5 now with the
idea of queen to c1
but now comes queen to d5 and now it's
not a problem
uh because well you're not only
threatening queen to g8 which would
get the black king running but also if
queen to c1 you can block checkmate with
queen to d1 so it's not a problem you're
still up for many pawns
uh so here we have queen to c1 check
bishop to d1
blocking with the bishop uh okay if you
block with the queen still queen
captures on f4 is coming so he blocks
with the bishop
and now comes queen captures an f4 so
winning a bag the pawn
but now comes queen to c5 with check
again a very very uh
very a good move uh king to g8 and now
queen captures an a7 again keeping an
eye on the back rank uh because
now now if queen to f1 we can just bring
the queen back queen to g1
and you can never go for a queen trade
because you are down two pawns it would
be an
a very easy win for white so instead
after queen captures an eight
on a7 we have h5 creating some breeding
room for the black
king also hoping for h4 h3 if you can
get
this diagonal open then the light square
bishop will be incredibly strong
so here we have h3 now you
you you no longer have to worry about
such things and uh
levon has a lot of time on the clock but
it will not help him uh
it's some 36 minutes for mahmoud europe
here and some hour and six minutes for
uh for levon but he's uh wasting more
and more time as
there simply are no moves and when there
are no moves to play you still have to
waste time to try and spot
that hidden brilliancy that saves you
the game but there is no such brilliancy
here
so bishop to c6 was played he of course
will still try
uh there are some possibilities here
maybe you can get some
queen to f1 check action queen to g1 and
then bishop captures on g2
so ideas like this are possible but
bishop to b3 check
king to h7 and now queen to f7 now
keeping an eye on the queen here
you don't have to worry about uh such
such things
so queen to see a queen to c1 with
check and here you had to calculate the
bishop captures on g2 and not just for
fun but also
because it actually might work but it
doesn't uh because
it will be too easy for white to do to
avoid all the checks for example queenie
for
check you will block with the queen
queen g6 check you're gonna go back king
h2 and now after queen to d6 check
you're going to play king to h1 and now
there are no more checks
this is covered this entire diagonal is
covered by the white queen
and i will just up up a piece and up a
pawn and you will very very easily win
this
so here after queen to f7 we have queen
to c1 with
check instead king h2 and queen to c5
now
now uh levon has to wait and see how
long
it will take for uh for mahmoud to win
the game so here we have queen to g8
with
check uh although this seems like very
straightforward there was a much
quicker win and it's uh it's actually a
pretty funny one if you guys want you
can even pause the video
and try to spot it because it is quite
nice again
while i give you a couple of seconds
don't mind me waving with the spoon
sometimes i hold
you know stuff while i make my videos so
you know if you happen to spot a spoon
it's it's totally cool
so after queen to c5 uh uh quinta g8 was
played but congratulations to
everyone who found queen to c7 and the
idea is very simple
you keep an eye on this diagonal so no
checks uh
can uh occur uh towards your king on h2
and are just threatening bishop to a4
and that's gonna win the bishop here it
sounds very easy
but it works so black might and of
course the bishop cannot move because
the queen hangs and if you try something
like queen b5 getting
out of the pin bishop to c to check and
after the king moves
now we play a4 uh there's also that
we're going to move the queen queen to
d5 but now
queen to b8 check our bishop covers the
h7 square king of seven and now bishop
b3 we're just going to win the queen
like this
so it was in the position but uh when
everything is winning it's
very hard to choose which winning uh you
know continuation you you're gonna go
go for so queen to g8 with check king to
h6 and
now queen to e6 with check we have g6 by
levon
and the queen to f6 now so now the idea
is we're going to play h4
will uh keep the king away from the g5
square
and try to deliver checkmate via via
queen to h8
square so here bishop to d7 and now
h4 and now this is the threat so of
course it has to be prevented queen c7
check
g3 and now queen to c8 blocking this
square
we have queen to f4 check king to h7 and
now queen to f7 check
and it was in this position that eleven
arjun resigned the game
uh as there is nothing more to be done
here uh this is move 40 so time control
has been reached there's really nothing
to hope for uh here
and uh uh well it it would be
pointless to continue levon tried for
for quite a few moves but it simply
wasn't enough mommy
found all the all the best continuations
and the two extra pawns will simply
prevail to give you an example
for example if king h6 we're gonna play
queen to f6
again threaten checkmate not for the
moment but the queen can't really move
uh and uh there's not much you can do if
bishop to f5 we're gonna play a4 we're
gonna start pushing our pass pawn
if bishop to c2 we're gonna play bishop
to d5 now keep an eye on this diagonal
also keep an eye on the queening square
and there's just no uh nothing you can
do here because you're just going to
push the pawn that's all there is
there's no a deeper uh
idea is not even needed the queen can
never leave the the back rank otherwise
queen to h it will be checkmate
and uh other than that you're just gonna
push your pawn that
that's just it if the bishop captures
the pawn
uh then again it's not a problem queen
to f4 check we pick up the bishop
since i know you guys were wondering but
what about the bishop
but yeah after queen to f7 check
levon resigned to the game and this uh
well very weird game
uh happened in in this round of the uh
of the super bad chess classic so uh
this takes mamadar after the lead
uh for the moment uh he uh the only
person who can catch up to momodaro in
this round i believe is wesley so but
he's still playing his game against
anish giri so we'll see what happens in
the
in that one uh probably going to show it
but we'll we'll see how it goes
so that's the game uh i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
alkamentsma henrik fola david kimura
michael
zakarias and derek lee for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day